et je me tourne enfin vers le seul qui
sait de quoi il parle c'est le fus
docteur martin blatche et est-ce que
vous pensez que l'on peut vivre la même
situation parce que là geoffroy le jeune
joue un peu sur les mots on ne dit pas
du tout la même situation qu'en mars
dernier
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
revivre cette situation ah non pas du
tout je crois pas une seconde de
confinement et je pense même qu'on
n'aurait pas dû fermer les bars et les
restaurants à marseille
vous savez j'ai été en contact et
désespèrent qui disent que le virus est
déjà en train de diminuer dans l'eau à
marseille ils ont les courbes
épidémiques sont déjà en train de
redescendre et c'est la même chose à
bordeaux et les résultats qu'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est des résultats qui ont
eu lieu il ya dix jours parce qu'elle
tant que les gens s'infecte après à la
période de contamination que les gens se
teste donc en fait on est d'emmener dans
une histoire de re confinement on est
très très loin en fait de cette
situation et très probablement que dans
les jours qui vont venir la situation va
s'améliorer et la critique on va leur
faire c'est plutôt pourquoi vous nous
avez fait paniquer pourquoi vous avez
fermer les bars pourquoi avait fermé le
restaurant
donc en fait pour moi cette émission est
ce qu'on va se confiner elle est presque
c'est de la science fiction quoi je
crois pas du tout qu'on va se confiner
le problème c'est que le gouvernement
raisonne avec un modèle qui est fait par
l'institut pasteur c'est une courbe
comme çà il prend le point qui hélas est
dit voilà où on va aller donc quand vous
avez une courbe comme ça vous pouvez que
vous posez la question de confiance mais
on est très très loin enfin je rappelle
quand même 40 pour cent quarante
patients en réanimation à marseille on
n'est pas dans une situation
cataclysmique le problème c'est quand
vous avez une courbe qui monte comme ça
forcément le décompte le recrutement est
donc en fait aujourd'hui on se pose
cette question pourquoi parce qu'on a
ces courbes et aussi parce qu'on a des
hospitaliers à l'hôpital qui n'ont
quitté en peuvent plus ils veulent plus
voir de coviva c'est à dire ils ne
veulent plus en voir c'est un espèce de
syndrome de stress post traumatique
sur cette première vague ils ont dû
reprendre tout le retard qu'ils avaient
et l'aïe revoit des patients avec le co
vise non mais non là c'est stop on en a
marre on n'en veut pas en plus on n'a
pas eu les lits et à la moitié des gens
qui sont en arrêt maladie parce qu'ils
ont été cassés par la première vague
sénart mais il ya plus il ya plus de
lits il ya plus de troubles il ya que
des généraux sans armes et voilà et
c'est ça la situation qui aujourd'hui
mais la situation réelle épidémique
il est question de confinement se pose
pas du tout et je pense effectivement
que olivier viron est dans une situation
extrêmement difficile aujourd'hui parce
que si ferme pas les bars et les
restaurants à paris on va lui dire deux
poids deux mesures vous avez fermé à
marseille on vous fermez pas paris alors
que je pense qu'au fond de lui il sait
qu'il a pas besoin de fermer à paris non
mais ça si l'avant je vous racontais
parce que vous êtes en train d'expliquer
qui a eu une mauvaise décision qu'on va
essayer d'équilibrer par une autre
mauvaise décès
c'est pour ça que c'est un morgien il ne
peut pas s'en sortir olivier ferrand il
s'est mis dans une impasse
hélas il ne peut rien ferment
gribouillis l'on comprend échapper à la
pluie ont retourné dans un fleuve
oui mais il ya autre chose le la
différence d'appréciation c'est pas
seulement entre vous et les hospitaliers
ça divise la communauté des médecins en
général comme en mai et qui méritait que
sur des faits attendez un scientifique
des statistiques vous ou d'autres vous
teniez un discours complètement la bonne
il ya 95% des médecins ce sont des
cliniciens dire que c'est des gens qui
sont dans les services ils savent
choisir une antibiothérapie ils savent
qu est ce qu il faut faire un scanner ou
une irm ça et ça fait requet ce qu'ils
voient ils sont dans leurs services ils
voient des patients arrivés ils
pensaient que c'était terminé
on a dit des camélias pas d'hôpital donc
c'est cette espèce de fameuses
dissociation il ya des cas il n'y a pas
de version live voix des patients
arrivés et ils en voient de plus en plus
ils voient pas un mur arrivé 1 ils ont
encore de la place pour les autres
patients mais ça monte petit à petit et
donc que tout ce qu'ils voient c'est
cette situation là mais c'est ils vous
disent simplement des patients donc nous
on pense qu'il faut faire quelque chose
de drastique parce qu'on veut plus avoir
de patients mais ce qui va se passer
demain et sans saveur et terre que eelv
on aurait vu vous inviter plus tôt mais
quand même 6 0 c'est juste en fait la
seule question c'est la perception de
l'avenir
il ya des gens qui vont un avenir
cataclysmique nous c'est parce qu'on
voit je pense qu'on a pu et par le fait
que c'est déjà diminué à marseille et à
bordeaux donc six a déjà diminué à
marseille à bordeaux
pourquoi ça va pas diminuer à paris
accor donc je pense qu'on n'est pas du
tout dans une situation où leur
confinement va s'imposer